joining us now first on cbs this morning
is naacp president
and ceo that's derek johnson derek it's
good to see you you have said that the
criminal justice system and the right to
breathe is on trial
so i know you watched the closing
arguments yesterday what are you
thinking as we're waiting for the
verdict
the prosecution made their case it was
very clear that our eyes told the truth
they backed it up with expert testimony
and they closed very strong and it's so
important
the world is watching and we cannot get
away from the fact that this is our
summer moment what do you mean
you know when you think about salmon
that was about voting reform
to allow our democracy to work right now
we're talking about our criminal justice
system
the reforms to ensure that we can
restore trust
and we can feel safe that's really
important for the african-american
community at this moment
how do you think the defense did that i
saw from some courtroom watchers that
many times the jurors were nodding with
some of the points that
eric nelson made yesterday that that bar
is low they just need one juror
to have doubt and so he throw everything
against the wall to see what happens
unfortunately in our system derek
shelvin has given
has been given due process that george
floyd was denied
and we must change how we have the
relationship between police and the
black community the naacp created 112
years ago
as anti-lynching what we witnessed was a
lynching
in the middle of the streets of
minneapolis minnesota
i know you were in college when the
rodney king verdict came in
do you see comparison between the two
well rodney king opened up the eyes to
the nation that what we have been saying
for
for decades in africa american community
that we're being harassed attacked and
killed by police
it was captured on videotape now for
this trial 30 years later
we can really say not only is it
captured on tape
that we must reform police policing in
our society
and we must make sure our criminal
justice systems reflect the needs and
interests
of all citizens particularly
african-americans yeah
we keep hearing about the calls for
police reform
how likely do you think that is given
this verdict i want to hear your
thoughts on that and i also want to get
you on the record about what maxine
waters said
you know the judge was clearly very
irritated and very angry about her
comments
what did you think you know we we love
congresswoman maxine waters but that's a
distraction let's stay focused on what
took place
in the outcome of this trial secondly we
must continue to push for reform as we
go abroad and send our troops to fight
for democracy fairness and justice we
must practice that here
and if we're unable to practice that
here we will lose confidence on the
global stage
but derek do you think that this will
lead to real change regardless of the
verdict
you know you know i appreciate
congresswoman karen bass she was
very strategic getting a george floyd
police reform act
out of a new congress without going
through the hearings now it's up to the
senate to act
so i am confident that senator cory
booker senator tim scott
will understand the magnitude of this
moment and step
up and really deliver something for all
of our nation
what would justice look like to you in
this particular case well we must do
away with qualified immunity
we must make sure that i mean in terms
of the verdict
it's guilty i mean you know richard
pryor who are you going to believe
your line eyes or me no let's our eyes
told us the truth
the prosecution made the case the expert
witnesses came up and say
he was killed because of derek shoving
there is no objection to that i don't
think anyone objectively looking at that
would deny that derrick shoving murdered
george floyd
okay well it's now in the hands of the
12 juries and as you know
it's like 12 wild cards thank you derek
for coming in this morning